THIS IS "THE FIVE."
MUSICAL MEDICAL >> Juan: IT'S AP
MUSICAL MEDICAL >> Juan: IT'S AC
MUSICAL MEDICAL >> Juan: IT'S AA
MUSICAL MEDICAL >> Juan: IT'S AH
MUSICAL MEDICAL >> Juan: IT'S AI
MUSICAL MEDICAL >> Juan: IT'S AN
CALIFORNIA.
THE PRESIDENT VISITING THE
LIBERAL STRONGHOLD AND HAVING
MAJOR DISAGREEMENTS WITH ITS
LEADERS.
THE PRESIDENT SETTING OFF LEGAL
ACTIVISTS AFTER RAISING MILLIONS
IN THE STATE.
OUTSIDE ONE OF THE FUND-RAISERS
IN BEVERLY HILLS.
THIS HAPPENS AFTER HOLLYWOOD
CELEBRITIES THREATENED TO OUT
HIS DONORS.
THREATEN TO ATTACK CITIES THERE
SAYING "WE CAN'T LET LOS ANGELES
DESTROY THEMSELVES BY ALLOWING
WHAT'S HAPPENING."
THERE ARE POLICEMEN WHO ARE
GETTING SICK.
THEY ARE ACTUALLY SICK.
THEY ARE GOING TO THE HOSPITAL
HERE AND WE LET THAT HAPPEN.
AND EARLIER TODAY, TO SET ITS
OWN AUTO EMISSION STANDARDS.
LET ME BEGIN WITH YOU.
AUTO EMISSION STANDARDS.
I WOULD THINK THAT MOST
CONSERVATIVES WOULD SAY THAT'S A
STATES RIGHTS ISSUES.
>> Emily: I THINK PART OF HIS
ARGUMENTS, WHICH I FIRMLY
SUPPORT, THE ABILITY NOW FOR THE
MARKET TO SET PRICES RATHER THAN
THE STATE TO DO IT IN KIND OF
THIS MANUFACTURED WAY.
IF I CAN SPEAK FOR A SECOND TO
ON HIS DISAGREEMENT "WITH THOSE
LIBERAL LEADERS" HE'S EXACTLY
EXACTLY RIGHT.
THERE WAS A LETTER THAT
GOVERNORS SEND TO TRUMP ON
BEHALF OF MOST OF THE MAYORS.
HE SAID IT WAS A DECADE OLD
PROBLEM.
TO INCREASE THE VALUE OF THE
VOUCHERS.
I WOULD BE SAYING, WHERE IS MY
TAXPAYER MONEY THAT I GAVE YOU
LAST YEAR?
WHERE IS THE ADDITIONAL BILLION
DOLLARS IT WAS JUST BUDGETED FOR
MY TAX DOLLARS?
WHERE IS THAT GOING ON DOMINIC
NOW?
THEY ARE ARGUING WITH THE
PRESIDENT SAYING THAT HE IS NOT
INTERESTED IN FIXING
HOMELESSNESS.
EVEN THOUGH THEY ARE SPENDING
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS.
IT WILL START AN EPIDEMIC IN
THAT STATE.
>> Juan: WILL GO TO
HOMELESSNESS, BECAUSE THERE IS
SO MUCH.
TRUMP IS IN CALIFORNIA.
GO RIGHT AHEAD.
>> Dana: THIS HAS BEEN GOING
ON FOR A LONG TIME.
CALIFORNIA, AS YOU MIGHT
REMEMBER, YOU ARE A LITTLE
OLDER.
>> Greg: AM I?
53.
>> Dana: IT'S AMAZING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: WHAT SURGERY CAN DO.
>> Dana: YOU'RE GOING TO PUT
UP WITH THAT?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: IN CALIFORNIA HAS
LONG HAD AIR QUALITY ISSUES.
THEY WERE GIVEN PERMISSION TO
DEAL WITH THEIR AIR QUALITY
ISSUES, MEANING, POLLUTION.
REMEMBER HOW BROWN IT USED TO BE
IN LOS ANGELES PEERED WHAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TALKING ABOUT
IS ABOUT GREENHOUSE GASES.
ABOUT CLIMATE CHANGE.
CLIMATE CHANGE DOES NOT JUST
AFFECT CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS LIKE A CARBON GOES, ONE
MOLECULE GOES ALL THE WAY AROUND
THE WORLD IN SEVEN DAYS THERE
AND SO, --
>> Greg: OH, WOW.
>> YOU LIKE THAT FACT QUESTION
MUST BE ONE THAT'S AN AMAZING
FACT.
>> Dana: YOU ARE NOT GOING TO
BE ABLE TO DICTATE THE REST OF
THE WORLD, WHILE THE REST OF THE
COUNTRY'S EMISSIONS WHEN IT
COMES TO SAFETY AND MILES PER
GALLON, JUST BECAUSE OF CLIMATE
CHANGE.
THAT'S MORE OF A UNIVERSAL
THING.
I THINK IT GOT A LITTLE BIT OUT
OF WHACK.
IT'S JUST NOT ABOUT AIR QUALITY.
YOU CAN STILL DO THINGS IN TERMS
OF POLLUTION.
OTHER CITIES HAVE DONE THAT.
>> Juan: JESSE, WHAT YOU SEE
THOUGH IS THAT 66% OF AMERICANS
OPPOSE THE PRESIDENT.
FUEL EFFICIENCY STANDARDS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, 66% OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT THEIR OWN
STANDARDS.
THE CAR COMPANIES ARE SAYING, WE
ARE WILLING TO GO ALONG WITH
CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE WE SEE THE
ADVENT OF ELECTRIC CARS, GETTING
CARS TO MOVE.
>> Jesse: THE CAR COMPANIES
WANT A UNIFORM STANDARD.
HE HASN'T STOPPED IT.
HE'S JUST STOPPED IT FROM
GROWING TO A UNIFORM HEIGHT
WHICH ACTUALLY CAN KILL PEOPLE.
IF YOU MAKE IT LIKE 58-55 MILES
PER GALLON OR WHATEVER, YOU ARE
CREATING THESE VERY, VERY LIGHT,
COSTLY CARS.
YOU GET INTO AN ACCIDENT WITH A
CAR LIKE THAT, THERE'S MORE
PEOPLE THAT DIE.
CARS ARE GOING TO BE SAFER,
BECAUSE THEY ARE GOING TO BE
STRONGER AND THEY'RE JUST GOING
TO BE A LITTLE MORE AFFORDABLE
FOR REGULAR MIDDLE-CLASS
AMERICANS.
I THINK THAT'S FINE.
IN TERMS OF THE HOMELESSNESS
SITUATION, CALIFORNIA WANTS TO
BE A REPUBLIC.
THEY IGNORE FEDERAL MARRIAGE
LAW, FEDERAL DRUG LAWS.
THEY ARE ALWAYS IGNORING THE
FEDERAL LAW.
THEN, ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY HAVE
THIS HOMELESS CRISIS, AND THEY
SAY, HEY FEDS, CAN WE HAVE SOME
OF YOUR MONEY TO FIX THIS?
DEMOCRATS CONTROL EVERY LEVEL OF
GOVERNMENT, SO WHY AREN'T THEY
DOING ANYTHING ABOUT A QUESTION
MARK SCOTT ADAMS RETORTED A VERY
NICE ARTICLE THE OTHER DAY AND
IT SAYS, WHY CALIFORNIA
KEEPS MAKING HOMELESSNESS WORSE.
A NUMBER OF REASONS.
THEY HAVE NO MANDATORY TREATMENT
IF SOMEONE IS RUNNING AROUND
LIKE CRAZY, A LUNATIC, THEY
CAN'T HELP THOSE PEOPLE.
AND THEY SCREWED UP THEIR
HOUSES.
OTHER WARM WEATHER STATES LIKE
ARIZONA, HAS LESS TAX REVENUE
THERE THEY DON'T HAVE THIS
PROBLEM, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
STRONG OVERSIGHT.
THE LONG ENFORCEMENT.
THEY COORDINATE WITH THEM.
THEY DON'T LET DRUG ADDICT,
CRAZY PEOPLE ROAMED THE STREETS
AND KEEP COMING IN AND OUT OF
PRISON.
SO, IF YOU LOOK AT THE WAY
THEY'VE MISMANAGED THIS, THINK
ABOUT HOW THEY'VE MISMANAGED THE
HIGH-SPEED RAIL?
REMEMBER THE STRAIN THAT WAS
SUPPOSED TO GO FROM
SAN FRANCISCO TO LOS ANGELES?
IT WAS SUPPOSED TO TAKE TEN
YEARS.
WE WERE GOING TO DO IT UNDER
THREE HOURS.
NOW, THEY HAVE A COST OVERRUN OF
$44 MILLION, 13 YEARS IN
ADDITION TO THE TEN YEARS IT'S
GOING TO TAKE.
AND NOW, IT'S GOING TO TAKE OVER
THREE HOURS TO GET TO AND FOR
ALL.
THEY'VE BARELY LAY DOWN ANY
TRUCK EITHER.
SO, IF WE CAN'T EVEN DO
SOMETHING LIKE THAT, NO WONDER
THEY CAN'T FIX THE HOMELESS
PROBLEM.
>> Dana: HOW CAN YOU CITE TO
SCOTT ADAMS FOR A RETWEET AND
NOT GIVE CREDIT TO THE GUY WHO
WROTE THE ARTICLE?
[LAUGHTER]
SPEAKER THANK YOU.
SO, GREG.
LET'S START WITH HOMELESSNESS.
>> Greg: RIGHT.
>> Juan: I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP LIKES THIS,
BECAUSE HE LIKES TO GO AFTER
DEMOCRATS WHO RUN BIG CITIES.
THE ONE RIGHT.
>> Juan: AGAINST DEMOCRATIC
RON OR LIBERAL.
HE'S NOT DOING THIS IN KENTUCKY
OR WEST VIRGINIA.
>> Greg: HE'S DOING A LOT WITH
THE OPIATE THING.
WHETHER OR NOT I ACTUALLY AGREE
WITH SOME OF THE THINGS HE'S
DOING.
SO WHAT.
SO WHAT IF THIS IS A POLITICAL
STUNT QUESTION WORKS SERIOUSLY.
SO WHAT.
IF A POLITICAL STUNT RESULT IN
SAVING THE LIVES OF A LOT OF
PEOPLE, GETTING PEOPLE OFF THE
STREET, GETTING PEOPLE INTO
TREATMENT, I SAY, LET'S HAVE
MORE POLITICAL STUNTS.
I'M FOR POLITICAL STUNTS IF THEY
ACTUALLY SOLVE PROBLEMS.
BUT WHAT'S INTERESTING TO ME IS
HOW DO YOU GET SUCH NEGLECT TO
BE ACCEPTABLE FOR SO LONG?
BECAUSE YOU LIVE IN A HUGE STATE
WHERE THE RICH NEVER HAVE TO SEE
THE POOR.
THIS IS THE ULTIMATE INEQUALITY.
THE RICH NEVER HAVE TO GO
DOWNTOWN.
THEY DON'T TAKE THE SUBWAY.
I DON'T KNOW ANYBODY WHO TAKES
THE SUBWAY AND ALLIE.
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           G
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           V
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           R
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           O
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           I
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           N
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           C
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           L
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           F
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           R
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           I
BEING THE GOVERNMENT           A
IS SUCH A CUSHY JOB, BECAUSE THE
RICH DON'T HAVE TO CARE ABOUT
THE TAXES, BECAUSE THEY CAN
AFFORD IT.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO CARE ABOUT
THE HOMELESS, BECAUSE THEY NEVER
SEE THEM.
THEY DON'T HAVE TO CARE ABOUT
THE DISEASE THAT'S BEEN SPREAD,
BECAUSE THEY WILL NEVER STEP
FOOT THERE.
THEY DON'T CARE BECAUSE THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY PRESSURE.
IF YOU SUBTRACT POLITICS AND THE
MEDIA, WHO ARE BASICALLY DRIVING
DIVISIVE BUSINESS MODELS, YOU
COULD SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS, AND
YOU COULD ACCEPT THAT TRUMP
WOULD, BUT YOU CAN'T EXPECT
TRUMP TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM,
BECAUSE YOUR EGO WON'T LET IT.
WE ALL KNOW WE WANT TO GET DRUG
ADDICTS OFF THE STREET.
WE WANT TO GET THE MENTALLY ILL
INTO INSTITUTIONS, AND WE WANT
TO GET PEOPLE WHO ARE TRULY DOWN
ON THEIR LUCK TO GET WHAT THEY
NEED.
>> Juan: I THINK THE ONLY
SOLUTION I'VE HEARD THOUGH IS
THERE IS A FEDERAL OFFICE
BUILDING VACANT, AND HE'S GOING
TO MAKE THAT AVAILABLE.
BUT THAT'S NOT SPEAKING TO THE
ISSUES.
>> Dana: I WAS JUST GOING TO
SAY, THEY HAVEN'T PRESENTED ALL
THAT THEY WOULD DO.
THAT WAS A POSSIBILITY.
I THINK THAT IF IT'S A POLITICAL
STUNT, I THINK IT'S POLITICALLY
SMART FOR REPUBLICANS TO
CAMPAIGN IN CALIFORNIA, BECAUSE
REMEMBER, ONE OF THE THINGS OF
THE DEMOCRATS CONSTANTLY SAY IS
THAT HE LOST THEIR VOTE.
BUT IF HE COULD INCREASE HIS
MARGINS WHERE YOU DO STILL HAVE
POCKETS OF CONSERVATIVES, IT'S A
BIG STATE.
I'M NOT GOING TO SAY THAT A
REPUBLICAN CAN WIN CALIFORNIA IN
2020, BUT CAN YOU INCREASE THE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE THAT VOTE FOR
YOU?
YEAH.
I WOULD.
HE'S RAISING A TON OF MONEY FOR
HIS CAMPAIGN.
>> Emily: WE DID A WHOLE
HOMELESS SEGMENT.
I DID THIS WITH DR. DREW.
IT'S A MULTIFACETED ISSUE.
WHAT'S SO DISTURBING ABOUT THE
GOVERNOR SAYING THAT IT'S ONLY
ABOUT AFFORDABLE HOUSING, FIRST
OF ALL, HE IS IGNORING HIS PAST.
WHEN HE WAS MAYOR OF
SAN FRANCISCO, CASH DID NOT
WORK.
THERE IS STILL A HOMELESS
PROBLEM THAT IS INCREASING BY
THE YEAR.
BY CONTINUING TO FOCUS ON JUST
ONE ASPECT OF IT, THEY ARE
IGNORING EVERYTHING ELSE THAT
THIS PRESIDENT IS AT LEAST
TOUCHING ON.
EVERYONE SHOULD CARE EXACTLY WHO
IS ADDRESSING IT AND WHO IS NOT.